c'est noël c'est c'est dans le monde
entier et ça doit se souhaiter à sa
population et au monde entier un joyeux
noël
j'avais pas remarqué qu'ils nous avaient
pas soin et souhaiter un joyeux noël et
je pense pas que ce soit très important
donc ils manifestent de l'engouement
pour les religions des dvd français non
je pense pas moi je trouve ça choquant
c'est choquant puisque déjà dans un
premier temps je suis musulman et dans
1/2 second temps je suis né en france
donc on a grandi avec ça donc
franchement ils auraient dû il aurait dû
présenter enfin les voeux les voeux du
père noël comme si je puis je dire est
pas sans moi ça me choque
personnellement pourtant sur un musulman
pratiquant
donc ouais c'est choquant un petit peu
fait c'est président doit montrer
l'exemple en fait ça que je me dis en
fait donc tu dois être
il a eu tort de faire ça c'est une
affaire privée ici la religion ça n'a
rien à voir avec la mairie où c'est une
fessée comme ça il fait en france
je ne dis pas que c'est bien j'espère
que c'est mal c'est différent
et je crois que ba désastre personnel
moi c'est pas quelque chose à kim
affecte directement qui emmanuel macron
de mais pas souhaité un joyeux noël
après je pense que le rôle d'un
président c'est aussi du coup d'être l'
arbitre de la nation et d'assurer un peu
l'unité de la nation donc de montrer un
soutien peu importe la forme ce soir à
une adresse directe vous peut-être un
tweet à
à une population qui fêtera une certaine
fait je pense que oui c'est toujours
bienvenu mais je pense pas que ce soit
un problème en tant que telle ait
vraiment un sujet société de souligner
le manque en tout cas de salut de
célébration de la part de manuel mac